OF TRAGEDY.
FIRST, IT IS CLEAR THAN EVER
THOUGHT TONIGHT
THOUGHT TONIGHT THIS IS THE MOST
RADICAL, THIS IS THE MOST
EXTREME AND FAR IT WHIFFED OUT
OF THE MAINSTREAM TICKET OF ANY
MODERN AMERICAN POLITICAL PARTY
IN HISTORY.
GUEST WHAT, IT LOOKS LIKE
REALITY IS NOW BEGINNING TO SET
IN FOR EVER SO SLOW AND
FORGETFUL JOE AS HIS CAMPAIGN IS
EVOLVING INTO A FULL-BLOWN PANIC
TONIGHT.
YESTERDAY HIS CAMPAIGN PRESS
SECRETARY AT A COMPLETE ON-AIR
MELTDOWN DISASTER WHEN ASKED
SIMPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT BIDEN’S
POSITION ON THE TRACK TRAINA
CHINA TRAVEL BAN.
WHETHER JOE NEEDS TELEPROMPTER
TO GET THROUGH SOFTBALL
INTERVIEWS BECAUSE LOOK AT THIS
RECENT INTERVIEW FIGHTING GETS
THE QUESTION.
MOVE IT UP MOVE IT UP.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
YEAR IT MINISTRATION WILL DO TO
HELP THEM GET THAT CHANCE.
THANK YOU.
>> MOVE IT UP.
YOU KNOW, IT USED TO BE A BASIC
BARGAINING AND IN THIS COUNTRY.
WORKERS SHARED IN THE WEALTH
THEIR WORK HELPED CREATE.
>> MOVE IT UP.
IT GETS WORSE BECAUSE BIDEN
TONIGHT CAUGHT ANOTHER LIGHT.
NEW YORK POST EXPOSING ITS
HISTORY OF FALSELY CLAIMING THAT
HE PREDICTED THE 9/11 ATTACKS.
JOE EVEN IMPOSED THAT BIN LADEN
RAISE.
LAST NIGHT HE REPORTEDLY HAD
BIZARRE MOMENT TELLING OF
CAMPAIGN FUNDRAISER HE HOPES THE
DEBATES DON’T EVOLVE INTO AN
ALL-OUT BRAWL.
REALLY, JOE?
YOU MIGHT WANT TO FOCUS ON
FIGURING OUT HOW MUCH COFFEE
YOU’RE GOING TO DRINK THE DAY OF
THE DEBATE AND HOW YOU’RE GOING
TO ANSWER A QUESTION WITHOUT A
TELEPROMPTER.
BECAUSE OF COURSE BIDEN HAS A
HISTORY OF THIS SORT OF VICIOUS
RHETORIC AS OTHER DEMOCRATS DO.
REMEMBER BIDEN?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PRESS ASKED ME DON’T I
WISH I WAS DEBATING HIM.
KNOW I WISH WE WERE IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND I COULD TAKE HIM
BEHIND THE GYM.
>> I’D DIDN’T MAKE A MISTAKE,
BUT THEY ASKED ME WHAT I LIKE TO
DEBATE THIS GENTLEMAN, I SAID NO
, IF WE WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND TAKE HIM BEHIND THE GYM.
>> JOE WOULD PROBABLY JUST FALL
OVER.
BY THE WAY COMMIT NOT JUST BIDEN
, BUT EVERY CORNER OF THIS
NEW RADICAL EXTREME DEMOCRAT
SOCIALIST PARTY THEY HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT WRITING NONSTOP HATRED
AND RAGE, AND ENCOURAGING WELL
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN WITNESSING
WELL OVER 100 DAYS NOW.
GAS WHAT, WE’LL JUST GIVE YOU A
SMALL SAMPLE.
>> SADLY THE DOMESTIC ENEMIES TO
OUR VOTING SYSTEM AND HONORING
ARE CONSTITUTION OUR RIGHT AT
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE WILL
WITH THEIR ALLIES IN THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED STATES
BEARS.
>> IF YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
CABINET IN THE RESTAURANT, AT A
GAS FILLING STATION,.
>> WHEN THEY GO WELL, WE KICKED.
>> WE’RE NOT GOING TO STOP
BEFORE ELECTION DAY IN NOVEMBER
AND THEY’RE NOT GOING TO STOP
AFTER ELECTION DAY.
EVERYONE SHOULD TAKE NOTE OF
THAT ON BOTH LEVELS, THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO LET UP AND THEY
SHOULD NOT.
>> I DON’T EVEN KNOW WHY THERE
AREN’T UPRISINGS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
>> I WILL PUT MISTER BURGESS UP
AGAINST SEAN HANNITY.
HE WILL TEAR THEM UP.
>> THAT’S OBAMA THREATENING ME.
ASK YOURSELF AFTER HEARING ALL
OF THIS, DEMOCRATS HAVE AN ALPHA
LIKE LIKE THEY ARE ENCOURAGING
WHAT WE’VE BEEN WITNESSING
PLAYING OUT IN CITIES AND
STREETS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
OF COURSE DENYING THE REALITY.
WHAT RESPONSIBILITY TO THESE
DEMOCRATS AND JOE BIDEN HAVE FOR
REFUSING TO CONDEMN THE RIOTING,
DENYING IT FOR MONTHS, AND NOW
IT COMES AS BARELY THERE
FORGETFUL JOE AND HIS CAMPAIGN
CONTINUED TO SPIN IN A MILLION
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS FLIPPING
AND FLOPPING AND FLAILING ON
EVERYTHING FROM FRACKING TO THE
TRAVEL BAN, VIOLENT RIOTING HE
CALLED MOSTLY PEACEFUL.
EVEN MANUFACTURING AND TRADE HE
IS LYING ABOUT.
LISTEN TO HIM YESTERDAY TALKING
ABOUT SUPPORT FOR THE FAILED
NAFTA DEAL THAT TRUMP
RENEGOTIATED.
NOT HIM AND NOT BROCK.
GUESS WHAT, THEY DIDN’T DO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM, THEY
DIDN’T DO POLICE REFORM, THEY
DIDN’T DO OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND
THEY DIDN’T CHATTER KNOW, THEIR
RECOVERY, LET’S SEE, THE WORST
SINCE THE ’40s 13 MILLION MORE
AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS
8 MILLION MORE IN POVERTY, JOE
PERRY THAT’S AFTER EIGHT YEARS.
YOU’RE HIS VICE PRESIDENT, WHAT
HAVE YOU ACCOMPLISHED IN 50
YEARS.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU RENEGOTIATED NAFTA AND
YOU DIDN’T IS THE POINT.
>> BECAUSE WE HAD A REPUBLICAN
PUNKERS THAT WOULDN’T GO ALONG
WITH US RENEGOTIATING.
>> DOESN’T HE DESERVE SOME
CREDIT FOR THAT?
>> IT IS BETTER THAN NAFTA.
>> WHIPS, TRUMP IS BETTER THAN
BIDEN.
HIS PLAN WORKED OUT MUCH BETTER.
ASK YOURSELF THIS, WHY ISN’T HE
CHANGING HIS TUNE, TRYING TO
MISDIRECT VOTERS?
BECAUSE LET’S SEE COME UP BIDEN
DOESN’T IN ANYTHING.
HE IS A PROFESSIONAL ALL TALK
AND NO ACTION POLITICIAN BIRD
THE EMBODIMENT OF ALL THE THINGS
ALL TALK, ALL TALK, ALL PROMISES
.
GETS NOTHING DONE.
HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT
YEARS I CAN THINK OF A SINGLE
THING HE DID IN THAT TIME TO
MAKE AMERICAN LIVES BETTER.
DONALD TRUMP KEPT ALL HIS
PROMISES AND THE STRUGGLES DON’T
STOP THERE BECAUSE THE EVER SLOW
AND FORGETFUL JOE IS BEHIND ON
ENTHUSIASM, BEHIND ON POLICY,
AND HIS POLLS ARE COLLAPSING
AFTER EMBRACING SOCIALISM AND
THE ECONOMY KILLING GREEN NEW
DEAL.
HIS PLAN GOES BEYOND THAT
PLEDGING TRILLIONS IN THE NEW
GREEN DEALS, SO HE’S BEING
FORCED TO TRY TO ERASE HIS PAST
POSITIONS, REWRITE HISTORY DAILY
.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA THEY JUST
IGNORE IT ALL PRETENDING LIKE HE
NEVER SAID THAT HE WAS IN FAVOR
OF REDIRECTING FUNDS AWAY FROM
THE POLICE AND SAYING THE POLICE
BECOME THE ENEMY AND TRYING TO
PRETEND THAT HE NEVER SAID HE
WOULD BE IN FRACKING, NOT ONCE,
BUT TWICE, NUMEROUS TIMES, BUT
TRY TO PRETEND LIKE HE’S
ACCOMPLISHED SOMETHING AFTER
BEING IN WASHINGTON NEARLY 50
YEARS.
THIS SHOW WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THE JOB THE MOB IN THE MEDIA
WILL NEVER DO.
ACTUALLY TELL YOU THE TRUTH,
VETTING THE CANDIDATES JOE BIDEN
, BECAUSE GUESS WHAT, HE
ALREADY PUT DOWN HIS FAR LEFT
WISHLIST.
IT’S ON PAPER INSTATED PROMISES
HE MADE WITH BOLSHEVIK BERNIE
HIMSELF.
THE MANIFESTO RELEASED THIS
SUMMER LAYS OUT AND ALL THE
DETAIL YOU EVER WANT TO COMMIT
THE NEW EXTREME RADICAL
SOCIALIST WALLACE DEMOCRATIC
PLANS FOR YOUR FUTURE.
110 PAGES OUTLINES MASSIVE TAX
INCREASES.
TRILLIONS OF NEW INCREASES.
WIDE OPEN BORDERS.
IT’S ESSENTIALLY AN
ALL-ENCOMPASSING WELFARE STATE
WHERE EVERYTHING BASICALLY IS
FREE, WHICH MEANS THAT IT WILL
BE FUNDED BY YOU, WE COME AT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE TAXPAYERS.
NOW THESE ARE BIDEN’S STATED
PROMISES THAT HE’S PUT IN
WRITING.
THE MANIFESTO MAKES CLEAR THAT
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT PAGE 17, NO ONE
SHOULD HAVE TO SPEND MORE THAN
30 PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME FOR
HOUSING.
WHO’S GOING TO PAY FOR THE REST
OF THAT MORTGAGE?
THAT SOUNDS LIKE IT WAS WRITTEN
BY AOC.
THE DOCUMENT PROVES THAT BIDEN
SHARES SIMILAR TO BOLSHEVIK
BERNIE ON HEALTHCARE.
AT SUBSIDIZED GOVERNMENT RUN
OPTION.
BIDEN ALSO VOWED TO IMPLEMENT A
VERSION OF THIS NEW GREEN DEAL,
IT WILL GO FURTHER THAN AOC NEW
GREEN DEAL AND PUTTING HER ON
HIS CLIMATE UNITY TASK FORCE AND
PHASING OUT ALL FOSSIL FUELS IN
15 YEARS.
THAT WOULD BE THE LIFEBLOOD OF
THE WORLD’S ECONOMY.
ADDITIONALLY, HE WANTS HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS IN NEW SOLAR PANELS,
WHICH WE KNOW WILL MEAN HIGHER
ENERGY PRICES FOR ALL BUSINESSES
AND EVERY AMERICAN.
BY THE WAY, WE WILL NOW BE
DEPENDENT ON OUTSIDE ENERGY
AGAIN.
WHILE THE PLAN DOESN’T
EXPLICITLY CALL FOR DISMANTLING
THE POLICE, THEY WANT A CIVILIAN
CORPS OF UNARMED FIRST
RESPONDERS.
OKAY, WE’RE GOING TO SEND IN THE
PSYCHIATRIST INTO A POTENTIALLY
VIOLENT SITUATION.
DOMESTIC DISPUTE, WHAT EXACTLY
DOES THAT MEAN?
IT SOUNDS AN AWFUL LIGHT LIKE
DEFUNDING THE POLICE LIKE HE
SAID HE WOULD DO.
THE BIDEN BERNIE MANIFESTO ALSO
CALLS FOR THE ELIMINATION OF
CASH PAYOUT.
THEY DID THAT IN NEW YORK.
OKAY, ANARCHY IS GETS ARRESTED,
THEY GET SENT OUT THE SAME NIGHT
TO REJOIN THE ACTIVITIES WHICH
HAS BEEN A COMPLETE DISASTER
ALLOWING VIOLENT CRIMINALS BACK
OUT ON THE STREET WITH ZERO
CONSEQUENCES.
THEY WERE HAVING BANK ROBBERIES
GO ON,
GO ON, HE GOES OUT, ROBS ANOTHER
BANK AND DOES IT FIVE OR SIX
TIMES IN NEW YORK CITY.
BIDEN CARES ABOUT THE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES, HIS EDUCATION PLAN
WILL TAKE AWAY ALL CHOICE FROM
POOR AND WORKING FAMILIES WITH
THE WORST SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
FOR EXAMPLE HE WANTS TO BURDEN
CHARTER SCHOOLS WITH MORE
GOVERNMENT REGULATION PAIR T
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT SCHOOL
CHOICE PROGRAMS DON’T HAVE MUCH
OF A FUTURE AND IN JOE BIDEN’S
AMERICA.
THE GUY THEY DIDN’T WANT
INTEGRATION OF SCHOOLS BECAUSE
HE DIDN’T WANT HIS KIDS GOING TO
SCHOOLS THAT WERE RACIAL JUNGLES
.
GET THIS, NO STANDARDIZED
TESTING.
IF THERE IS BIDEN AND BERNIE,
THEY WANT TO ELIMINATE THAT TOO.
HOW DO WE KNOW HOW THE KIDS ARE
DOING.
HE WANTS TO END THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THE BORDER WALL.
HE WANTS TO IT IS PERHAPS THE
PRESIDENT’S GREATEST FIRST-TERM
POLICY ACHIEVEMENT, IN OTHER
WORDS, THEY WANT US TO BE THE
UNITED SANCTUARY STATES OF
AMERICA JUST LIKE KAMALA STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH
IMPLEMENTING A 100 DAY
MORATORIUM ON ANY DEPORTATION.
IT MEANS THAT ALL OF THIS IS A
PREVIEW OF COMING ATTRACTIONS.
HE’S TELLING YOU WHAT HIS AGENDA
IS.
THEY ARE READY TO UNLEASH ALL OF
THOSE.
BIDEN CAN TRY TO HIDE IT ALL.
BUT IT IS STILL OUT THERE.
THEY STILL WRITE IT DOWN ON
PAPER AND IT STILL THERE STATED
PLAN.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, BIDEN AND
HARRIS ARE READY AND ABLE TO
SURRENDER TO THE RADICALS THAT
ARE THEM AND NOW THEIR ENTIRE